he can try right christian but we'll
have to see if it comes true
employers in manufacturing are having a
tough time finding skilled technicians
but a new program being offered on the
college of southern nevada's henderson
campus
will change all that governor steve
siselek joined members of csn to show
off the new manufacturing program
programs in machine operation production
technicians robotics megatronics things
like that
it's going to be a big pipeline for
employers in manufacturing to hire from
as well as provide necessary training
for others looking to make a switching
careers
many individuals that may be displaced
now have other venues and other
sectors that they can look at for
employment and this is the fastest
growing sector in southern nevada
so it'll help diversify the economy it's
going to help people reconnect to
employment if in fact
you know the jobs that they were in
aren't coming back the expansion was
funded through a two million dollar
grant from the governor's office of
economic development wind fund
christian